[Music]
let's talk about pitch perfect this is
your baby this movie is I produced this
movie it was based on an autobiography
it was based on a nonfiction account of
four groups who who occupy low groups
it's it's a comedy set in the world of
competitive collegiate a cappella and
it's based on this all-female group who
goes to the national finals now acapella
when I was in college actually how I got
started in comedy is I I was the
comedian who would bring the acapella
groups onstage that's actually how I got
into this crazy business but back then
it was not cool has acapella become cool
since then well if you put it if you had
to rank it I would say like sports and
jocks and athletes and pretty people you
know like really smart people there's a
lot of things that would come on the
list before acapella what I didn't
imagine the answer pass like the
quarterback on the key no they have not
they have not but but what's great is
they you know especially in this movie
really show that they have a massive
amount of talent right and so even
though they're kind of dorky and they
get together to sing essentially and
back each other up with singing they
sing some really cool stuff and it's
really fun and then and they have a
great time they're like loving it and at
the end of the day they get to be rock
stars so you are the producer of this
film this is your chance you're on
television pitch this movie to the crowd
tell them why they should see it well if
you loved the Hunger Games
then you will love pitch perfect it is
exactly the same as the Hunger Games
- the killing of kids and plus like
singing and dancing and super fun laughs
it's really funny I mean it's basically
you know it's a great group of women you
had rebel Wilson yeah she's she's one of
the stars of the movie Anna Kendrick and
a camp Adam Devine from workaholics as
in the movie it's super fun good people
it's written by a writer of 30 rock so
we have a really good time we have a
clip here and I believe you are in this
clip you are a color commentator
yeah innate in the tradition of
best-in-show they talked about dogs we
talked about acapella singing and we
make really off-color jokes let's take a
look at this clip from pitch perfect
[Applause]
Treblemakers they're on the trail for
Lincoln Center huh absolutely they
always are Gail my favorite and
everyone's favorite
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh boy the bad boys of a cappella have
just gotten badder oh that's right
Johnny I should excuse myself to freshen
up the downtown tonight huh
[Applause]